Now let's discuss
the Secure Hash Algorithm or SHA.
The Secure Hash Algorithm
was developed by NIST.
The original algorithm is SHA-1.
SHA-1 produces a hash value of 160 bits.
Later, NIST revised the SHA standard and
specify the SHA-2 algorithms.
This algorithms have key lengths of 256,
384 and 512 bits,
and their operations
are similar to SHA-1.
This table compares the SHA parameters.
The message digest size refers to
the length of the hash value, so for
SHA-1 it is 160 bits, and for
SHA-512 the hash length is 512 bits.
Message size is a size
limit on the input.
You can consider these size limits
are not having an effect in practice,
because most if not all
messages will be smaller.
For example, even with SHA-1,
the message size is limited to 2 to 64.
This means that you
can hash a message so
big that it occupies the entire
address space of a 64 bit computer.
You can also think about
it in another way.
2 to the 43 bits is already a terabyte.
As we can see,
the algorithms from left to right
produce hash values with more bits.
Hence, they are more secure as
we move from left to right.
For example, with SHA-1
because the hash value has 160
bits then the search space for the
attacker to find a collision is 2 to 80.
Whereas for
SHA-512 the search space is 2 to 256.
In this lecture we will provide
a description of SHA-512,
the other versions are quite similar.
For SHA-512 it takes as an input
a message that's smaller
than 2 to the 128.
Again, this is not a limit that
will have any impact in practice.
The output is a hash value
that is in 512 bits.
The input is processed block by
block and each block has 1024 bits.